when it comes to overwatch heroes that
just look real scary not many people
have an edge on reaper he is the grim
reaper he's cloaked in death and he's
got shotguns and he just yells die a lot
hey folks Chris waters here with Eric
Tay talking about overwatch giving you a
little tips on how to start off with
these characters and get into the fray
now Eric tey Reaper he's got those
shotguns
yeah Reaper is a deadly dude he eats up
supports he shreds
you know these weaker offensive heroes
with less health and he just has a lot
of sustainability really good on flanks
and can just be a nuisance yeah you get
him in next to tanks - it's gonna be
problems basically anyone next to a
Reaper advantage Reaper so how do you do
that how do you get close you want to be
working those flanks you want to be
walking around through passages getting
into close quarters one of the abilities
he can use to get there is his shadow
step which is a teleport yea shadow step
is amazing it lets you get to high
ground
it lets you teleport past you know the
enemy team which allows you to do these
amazing flanks because they don't think
you're going to come from there because
why would they look backwards right it's
a lot faster cool down now than it used
to be so use it as often as you can -
definitely caused a nuisance behind the
lines and get past them yeah look for
those opportunities there's a nice one
on the left side of early attack on full
sky industries you can get to a platform
across the water use it to get high
places like Eric was saying basically
any time you're coming at someone from
an angle they're not expecting so you
can get closer
that's when Reaper shines and once you
get close unload with those Hellfire
shotguns these things are deadly from up
close but you don't want to start firing
from too far away yeah they're going to
do very minimal damage from medium to
long range so you definitely want to be
like one or two hero lengths away so to
speak but definitely want to get close
to the widow-makers you know try sneak
up on them so you can take out those
snipers that are really pestering you're
your offensive team and keep in mind
with the teleport you do create a column
of smoke and loud audio cue whenever you
do that so alert heroes are going to be
paying attention also they're going to
be able to hear your footsteps when you
come closer because the louder the
footsteps the more damaging the
character so there are these things that
are working towards your detection still
you need to be stealthy you need to get
around and
get close and people rightfully fear you
another tool in your arsenal mobility
wise is called Wraith form this is a
great one
not just for closing distance because
you get you go a little fast and you're
invulnerable but also for getting the
heck out yeah I use it a lot to get the
heck out as you said basically when you
start getting low and you don't think
you're going to win the fight it's
probably time to Wraith the formal way
and you know try to find a med pack
knowing the maps is important with
Reaper because when you rate form you
need to get to that health or you need
to hope you know some of these other
heroes are dead and you can get that
reaping passive ability which lets you
pick up those sweet health orbs that you
desperately mean as Reaper you want to
keep an eye out for these glowing
orange globes because what that means is
someone has died and you can take some
of their health this is going to help
you stay alive so when you blast someone
go ahead and walk up gobble that soul
globe and keep on shooting with one big
caveat don't step over junk rat once you
kill him because he drops a whole bunch
of dynamite and you will die let his
dynamite poop explode and then get the
soul globe doing damage with his
shotguns his Reapers thing so of course
it makes sense that his alt would just
be doing a ton of damage with his
shotguns yeah basically you want to get
in as close to as many enemies as you
can because you're spinning whirlwind of
death basically you're going to spin 360
for a couple times just raining hell on
everyone with your shotguns and anyone
in your path is most likely going to die
now it's not the greatest against tanks
necessarily so hopefully they're at half
health or whatnot but you definitely
want to target supports DPS people if
they're on a payload or something like
that bunched up together it's probably a
good time to get in there and die die
die the three words that no hero wants
to hear because it's such a flashy alt
and it's such a deadly alt if you're
close so people are going to try to
neutralize you they're going to try to
if they see you coming take you out or
stun you while you're doing it so again
coming from an elevated position
dropping down and popping that alt
midair or just coming around the corner
and popping it before people see you
these are great ways to make sure you
get the most out of your death blossom
one more key thing to remember guys is
you only have eight shots with your
shotgun so it doesn't hurt to get in
that quick melee also that quick melee
kind of cancel the animation on the
reload so use that whenever you reload
definitely just a way to increase
your close quarters damage which is what
Reaper is all about get to teleporting
get to sneaking around enemy lines and
just start shredding people up with
Reaper form or overwatch hero guides
game spots YouTube channel is the place
to go folks and give us a subscribe
while you're there thanks for watching